من كده ثانوي ترند المسلسلات الاقل من 30
حلقه في عالم الدراما العربيه بدا يدخل
وشفنا اعمال كثيره من هذا النوع والسنه
الماضيه بدانا نشوف في رمضان مسلسلات من
15 حلقه كمان وهذه السنه الموضوع مكمل وفي
اعمال من هدول بداوا مع اول رمضان وخلصوا
وفي اعمال ثانيه لسه بادئه من كم يوم
بالتزامن مع 15 رمضان خلونا نستعرض مع بعض
هذه الاعمال
اللي شفناها هي الاعمال اللي بدا عرضها من
اعمال ال 15 حلقه لكن في ثلاث مسلسلات من
15 حلقه بدات مع اول رمضان وانتهت خلاص
اولها مسلسل واخيرا للنجمين قصي خولي
ونادين نسيم نجيم والقدير ومجموعه نجوم
اخرين ومسلسل الهرش السابع اللي حكينا عنه
بدايه الحلقه من بطوله امينه خليل ومحمد
شاهين واسماء جلال وعلي قاسم ومجموعه نجوم
اخرين والمسلسل الثالث اللي من 15 كمان
حلقه وانتهى عرضه ومسلسل وعود سخيه للنجمه
حنان مطاوع واللي محظوظين بانها منورتنا
اليوم في استوديو تفاعلكم في الفقره
الجايه
[موسيقى]